this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the global brand for men's
grooming and hygiene products
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and today we're gonna
party like it's thor's day even though
it's
wednesday episode 7 of what if is now
out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the story
easter eggs things you missed and also
discussing what could be happening in
the future of the series full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't checked it out
then check out now if you enjoy the
video then please hammer the thumbs up
button and i'll be your adopted brother
from another mother if you subscribe to
the channel without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
what if episode 7.
okay so the episode is heavily based
around thor and it reimagines the guy if
he lived the life of andrew wk showing
my age there but chris hemsworth has
returned to the role and he brings the
usual fun that you'd expect from the god
of thunder for the last couple of weeks
we've been somewhat in the multiverse of
sadness and in the lead up to this i was
expecting tony stark to get struck by
lightning
as the guy just can't seem to catch a
break however it does bring some levity
to what's been a very depressing season
and it ends with somewhat of an open
ending we know from the trailers that
party thor will be back before the
season closes out and we'll talk about
this later on in the video now as always
we open with the watcher narrating the
events of the show and those of you
who've been binge watching the series so
far might have noticed something about
him when the character first started off
in episode 1 he was simply a silhouette
amongst the cosmos but as the season's
gone on he's got closer and closer and
closer this has got to the point that we
can now see his full features and
clearly tell that he's basically the
baby from the teletubbies now if you've
been following our videos so far then
you'll know we reported on a leaked list
that apparently contained all of the
episode concepts according to that this
was going to be episode 5 and the zombie
one was gonna be number seven
they seemingly swapped the order of
those two and due to the way that the
watcher appears in the opening of this i
think we can now confirm whether it was
fake or not if we look at how he appears
in the zombie episode his face is
completely looking over everything
whereas here he's gone back a bit making
me think that the order was indeed
changed now shout out to philip molina
and the team at new rockstars who i've
been talking to about this for a week
and i think that it finally confirms
everything i think eventually he will
end up properly interacting with the
characters and that this might break the
multiverse open as he's clearly no
longer keeping his distance we know
they're coming down the line a lot of
them are going to be interacting and him
getting closer and closer could be
hinting towards this now the episode
asks the question what if thor was
raised as an only child without his
brother loki it reframes his entire life
so that odin didn't show pity upon him
and take him to asgard loki was of
course responsible for the majority of
issues in his brother's life and in the
first thor film he was the one who
slipped the frost giants into asgard so
that they could steal the casket of
ancient winters this set thor off on a
path in which he traveled to jotunheim
and almost started a war with the frost
giants which saw him cast out he then
ended up encountering shield defeated
his brother returned to earth to stop
him with the avengers and it's clear
that loki is the most defining character
in his life thus his absence sets him
off in a totally new direction that
seems well it does seem a bit more fun
for a bit
now we start off in new mexico much like
the beginning of thor with darcy and
jane sat in their truck similar to the
opening of the movie they're observing
an anomaly but unlike that film dr eric
selvig is not with them they're
predicting this to be the apocalypse and
in some ways they'd be right if you like
9 p.m bedtimes like your boy kevin
spoilers now this is the first time that
jane brings up the alpha star icarus
which we learn was wiped out in a
similar anomaly to what we see in the
episode darcy says they're here and this
is a nod to poltergeist namely when the
ghosts came into the protagonist's home
however here it's a different kind of
invasion and thor has come to mid god
with the warriors 3 and sif now you
might be asking why this thor can wield
the hammer and if you cast your mind
back to thor you'll remember that that
ability was only taken away from him
because odin put a spell on it therefore
it doesn't matter if he's worthy or not
as in the opening of his first solo
movie he could carry it even though he
was a bit of a douche in my avengers end
game breakdown a lot of people thought
that thanos was worthy because he
managed to grab stormbreaker and push it
into thor's chest but this was only
because it didn't have a spell on it
however magnet did and thus when
fighting cap thanos grabbed his wrist
instead of the hammer now what if i told
you my wife calls me wang the conqueror
well she doesn't but she might and
that's because for the last month i've
been using manscape's new all-in-one
performance package 4.0 this 4th
generation kit is the best way to trim
your infinity stones and it comes with a
brand new lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer
that provides a shave so close people
will think that razorfist did it the
lawnmower 4.0 is the sleekest electric
trimmer manscaped have ever released and
not only is it waterproof but it comes
with advanced skin safe technology that
provides a shave more stylized than tony
stark's beard it also has a super smart
cordless charging system that gives you
power for 90 minutes and led lights that
make it look like it's powered by the
arc reactor with it is an amazing travel
lock feature as well so it doesn't set
off when you're on the go and all you
have to do to activate it is click the
button three times on top of this the
pack also has two products i didn't even
know i needed until now and that is the
crop preserver ball deodorant and crop
revivable toner spray simply apply the
crop preserver after a shower for all
day body odor protection and use the
crop reviver on your infinity stones any
time of the day now i'm going to be
honest yeah i've got a
bit of a big snout so the weed whacker
was completely life-changing it helps to
get the nose hairs right at the back and
it's also got the same skin safe
technology that the lawnmower does so
you don't have to worry about cutting or
tugging on sensitive hairs now for a
limited time only you also get two free
gifts and these include the anti-chafing
boxer briefs and also the amazing travel
bag that puts a suit of armor around
your kit wherever you go go to
manscape.com and get 20 off as well as
free international shipping when you
enter heavy 20 at the checkout the link
is in the description below and just
enter heavy 20 at the checkout for this
life-changing deal i'm off to go save
some lives i'll see you next time or in
the rest of this video
now we got back to asgard to find odin
extremely weak in a bed much like how he
was in thor due to the film he was
powerless to stop loki and there was a
scene where he was joined by frigger and
loki instead of thor as he rested up
here however he's getting on a bit and
he just needs to rest up and get those 9
p.m bedtimes in like your boy kevin
spoilers we find friger at his bedside
and she leaves the kingdom telling thor
to have no parties which if you've ever
been a teenager means to have a party oh
seethor is clean-shaven throughout the
episode and i think that this is done on
purpose to show he's not trying to live
up to his father's image as much odin of
course had a beard which thor also did
and it made them look very very similar
maybe thor just never had the time to
shave in the saga as he was pretty much
always doing something world ending so
the fact that he's beardless here makes
me think that he's had a much quieter
life and therefore has had more time to
do it or i could be reading too much
into it and they've done that to
differentiate the characters now moving
on she says heimdall will be watching
and this is of course a nod to his eyes
which can see everything he's basically
santa claus minus the banter claws and
he won't be letting any parties go on
under his watchful eyes
or so he thinks now together with the
warriors and sith thor travels into
odin's treasure room and in the
background we can catch the fake
infinity gauntlet when the mcu first
started out many people thought that
this was the real one so we're wondering
how the infinity stones were off
somewhere else however it was quickly
debunked as being fake due to it being
for the wrong hand the party rages on
earth and in the crowd you can spot the
back of yondu's head it's not long until
we see the executioner from thor and the
god of thunder hands him a beer which he
says refills itself this is due to magic
and it is possible that it's one of
doctor strangers which we saw refilling
itself during their first meeting darcy
and jane go back and forth over whether
to talk to thor and then we get a cameo
by howard the doc who because of the
events of this reality never got caught
by the collector jane is clearly head
over heels due to some slo-mo gazing and
darcy rattles off just how amazing thor
looks throughout the mcu saga whenever
people have encountered him they've
often described how beautiful he looks
and this is no exception especially with
this clean-shaven face now this is the
perfect time to tell you about manska
i'm just i'm just kidding i promise i'm
just kidding now we see the meeting of
jane foster and thor and in this reality
rather than it being in the desert in
new mexico it shifted slightly so that
they meet in las vegas foster was very
much a florence nightingale s character
that fell in love with him but here he's
pretty much just boasting about how
amazing he is whilst getting scrolls to
transform into him this of course shows
his vanity as he's obsessed with staring
at himself through their faces jane taps
him on the shoulder and he says she's so
tiny if you cast your mind back to the
avengers the character actually called
humans tiny when he was under the
influence of the mind stone this was
clearly him showing his subconscious
thoughts about humanity but here he just
blurts it out though doesn't even know
what the norse god of thunder is and
this shows how detached years from
caring about anything other than himself
now he believes initially that she said
horse god and this could be a reference
to beta ray bill who is somewhat of a
horse now next he offers jane some food
and we see the grand master cutting a
giant cake and the character is once
more voiced by the infamous jeff
goldblum he's joined by his right hand
man or woman in topez who is carrying
the disintegration stick that completely
pardons you from life now later on we
catch the grandmaster on the decks and
this is of course similar iconography to
what we had in thor ragnarok when loki
and thor came face to face for the first
time after encountering heller topaz was
there too and ironically she died in
ragnarok when bruce set off the birthday
song and fireworks on the grandmaster's
ship now i was kind of hoping to see a
jacked grandmaster as we of course saw
an episode too that his brother was
however he's the same old same old but
you have to give the guy credit as he
looks good and on most other planets
he'd be
you'd be old so
um
so
now jane once more brings up the bifrost
portal which wiped out the alpha star
and it turns out that this was just thor
throwing another party and what a party
it is the night looks amazing and we
watched the characters busting out dance
moves so good that even zemo would be
jealous
next we see nebula and korg and i'm
guessing that the former did end up
being tortured by her father due to her
cybernetic parts which were not present
in episode 2. either way looks like
she's having fun and playing for a brand
new eye and we also get several more
cameos including valkyrie and drax turns
out that you are out of luck until
you've gone duck and we see darcy
getting shacked up with her brand new
man howard now i might be reaching here
and i often do but is it just me or does
the elvis impersonator carrying out the
wedding look a lot like a young kurt
russell kurt of course played ego and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and
personally i think that it's actually
him now we see thor and jane getting
tattoos together and these are magic and
signs which is a nod to the quote by
arthur c clarke magic's just science
that we don't understand yet this was
mentioned in the first thor film and it
says that they reference it here we
catch up in the morning after to find
everyone suffering from a hangover and
jane says phone phone over and over in a
croaky voice which sounds very similar
to et who gets name dropped in this
episode now that might be reaching and
you might also be able to hear that i've
got a very sore throat this morning
which i'm calling a thor throat a throw
or throat terrible now turns out that
the call she made to shield at the start
of the episode has come back to hunter
and both maria hill and crossbones have
been dispatched to bring her in it's
stuff like this which is why new rock
stars and canadian lad get more views to
me isn't it i'm absolutely terrible now
it turns out that nick fury arrived to
investigate the party but he was taken
out by korg performing a cannonball into
a vegas fountain amongst the quick shots
you can also catch rocket raccoon in the
sink and it looks like the little rabbit
has seen better days thor refers to him
as one and this is a call back to
infinity war in which he also called him
the same thing next we cut to a holly
carrier and learned from agent colton
that the party atmosphere is spreading
across the globe and that it's slowly
starting to destabilize it whilst jane
believes that this is earth's first
encounter with an alien lifeform shield
and veil like captain marvel actually
came here before and though she's not
technically an alien she does have cree
dna within her the beeper she left with
fury was of course only to be used in
extreme circumstances and it turns out
that shield are just big party poopers
they activate it which starts up the
captain marvel logo that we of course
saw at the end of infinity war back with
thor we see him taking selfies with
aisha aka the golden high priestess of
the sovereign who of course appeared in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. this
moment is interrupted by loki who has
arrived looking a lot more like a frost
giant than we've ever seen him before
because of frigger teaching him
witchcraft and the diet of asgard loki
ended up looking very different to the
typical frost giant however we see here
that because he was raised by them that
this variant looks exactly like them
though he initially seems like he's
going to be a bad guy the pair are very
much brothers from another mother and
this of course was actually the case in
the mcu loki only really went fully off
the deep end due to learning of his true
identity but not being lied to his
entire life has meant that he's a much
nicer guy he does have a similar sort of
crown to what loki had in the mcu but
this time it's made out of ice now at
this point we hear a sonic boom and
watch as captain marvel arrives on the
planet much like how she did at the end
of endgame i think it's hilarious how
the locations like france and belgium
all have names that you can see from the
sky and this is of course what you get
on a map captain marvel calls him white
snake and this is in reference to the
british band that were predominant in
the 80s captain marvel hasn't really
been to earth since the 90s so this is a
timely reference for her that really
shows her age now brie larson bloody
brie larson she's here to ruin
everyone's day and she ends up going
toe-to-toe with thor which could be the
greatest threat to the party that anyone
has ever seen he ends up using a
hammerang technique and this could be a
subtle nod to when he pulled
stormbreaker to his hand in the
beginning of endgame but this time he
didn't miss hey you're having that your
bloody party pooper now like captain
america did in the avengers she tells
him to put the hammer down but rather
than hitting it against his shield he
sends cap into stonehenge stonehenge
actually appeared in the mcu during thor
the dark world and it was the location
eric salvik traveled to when he went a
bit crazy this fight takes place across
the planet and our next stopping point
is the grand canyon where we see both
characters jiggered out in one of the
best battles in the season so far i love
how they fly over the skyline of the
planet and it feels very godly as they
crash into clouds whilst thunder erupts
around them though ends up beating her
by placing malnet on her chest and this
is similar to what he did to loki at the
end of his solo film thor slams her in
time out and she ends up being branded a
party pooper in a moment that feels like
it was written by the quartering back on
the helicarrier she brings up her pet
cat goose but at this time i'm sure he
was still on earth and under fury's care
i don't really care though i'm not that
much of a nerd and they want captain
well i am but they want captain marvel
to take thought down but due to her
powers this would destroy the party and
also the planet instead we need a
different woman for the job and this
comes in the form of jane who wants to
settle the situation without destroying
north dakota after loki destroys thor's
phone jane comes up with a plan to reach
out to friger who put an end to the
party like any other parent would across
the planet we see certa chatting up the
statue of liberty and he says he's got a
crown too which was of course the source
of his power in ragnarok however he just
ends up melting her arm off and we see
the destruction that he and the frost
giants bring to the planet they end up
creating ice structures at mount
rushmore and this includes a loki crown
thorns on abraham lincoln and also
george washington we jump to sydney and
see that the harbour bridge has been
turned into a dance floor now on the
dance floor we can catch corg busting
out the robot and sucking on a pacifier
this shot has several characters from
the mcu and next to him you will also
know as mantis there's also a skrull and
one of them fem bots from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 that yondu serviced i
think i can still say that and keep it
pg now there's also an asgardian god
which i will now call an asgard i think
this might actually be the same one that
loki imitated during thor the dark world
he did this after faking his death and
used them to take the throne but let me
know below if you think it's really him
or not now we can also catch meek and
valkyrie and just before thor goes to
slide down the opera house he's once
more approached by captain marvel they
end up fighting but luckily jane and
darcy make a noise so loud that it snaps
heimdall out of his slumber and he pulls
her through to asgard he then sends her
to go meet frigger as the battle on
earth rages on just as the nukes are
about to be launched frigger projects
herself to the planet and gives their
son a right good talking to this
de-escalates the problem and crossbones
feels bad they didn't get to fire the
nukes because at this point he would of
course been a part of hydra i feel kind
of bad for thor as he was just after a
good time but now he's in deep trouble
we see thor slowly start to become more
like his father as he wants to clean up
and he sees it as his duty to do so as
frigga races towards earth he digs deep
into his powers and commands the guests
to put everything back exactly how it
was this includes stonehenge the statue
of liberty's arm mount rushmore and he
also puts the leaning tower of pisa
straight which yeah obviously it's meant
to lean similar thing happened in
superman 2 as well so might be a nod to
that now frigate is suspicious but with
a little help from captain marvel she
ends up buying it though says so tiny
yet contains so much and this of course
symbolizes how he viewed others doing a
180. however the game is given away when
mullier returns covered in markings from
the days before kind of reminds me of
that time i threw a party and left one
bottle cap on the carpet and got caught
and in a lot of trouble now he ends up
organizing a day with jane and we get
somewhat of a happy ending until ultron
infinite arrives through a portal he
carries not only the infinity stones
with him but also vision's face and i'm
guessing that this is from a reality in
which he ended up shifting his
consciousness into the synthetic body
and this just made him unstoppable now
because this episode of what if has
ended on a cliffhanger i know a lot of
people will be a bit bummed out but as
we've been saying at the end of all our
breakdowns there is hope of a team
upcoming for the finale in two weeks
time in the second trailer for the show
we could catch several characters in an
avengers esque lineup and this included
killmonger thanora tuchar lord and
lastly party thor this shows that the
characters are definitely gonna be
interacting at some point and no marvel
are infamous for putting fake things in
their teasers there is more evidence to
support it last week the studio released
a mid-season sneak peek look at what's
to come and in that we could catch thor
meeting with strange supreme strange
supreme seems to be the connector
between every universe as we already
know from the second trailer that he's
going to be meeting captain carter so my
guess is that he breaks out of his
reality and then starts to unite the
multiversal heroes in order to stop a
greater threat in this clip thor also
mentioned zombies so my guess would be
that they pull one of the survivors from
episode 5 and form a team with them
though has also been spotted in the
teaser fighting ultron bots in las vegas
and therefore we can assume that the
leaks about the finale being an ultron
scented one are indeed true if you saw
the hyundai ad then you'll know that
showed several of the heroes fighting
against the legion of ultron bots and
it's likely that this is what will
happen when the season draws to a close
as for next week we are apparently going
to have a gamora centric one in which he
ends up wearing thanos armor i'm gonna
guess that he was killed and that she
ended up taking on her father's legacy
in an attempt to balance the universe
we'll soon find out but i think that
would be a very very cool concept
now as for my thoughts on the episode i
think this was probably one of the
weaker ones for me and though it had
lots of cameos and easter eggs i just
wasn't as gripped as i was with the
other entries i don't know if it's
because i'm a dc head at heart but i
just love dark concepts and infinity war
is my favorite mcu movie because it
takes a lot of the fun elements and
subverts them so much that's probably
why i love the darker episodes of what
if but this yeah i sound a bit down but
it was still pretty good i know a lot of
people in my comments have been saying
that the tone of what if namely the
back-to-back tony deaths kind of made
the season seem very bleak so if this
was originally episode 5 then that might
have brought a bit more levity to the
situation so it didn't feel like gut
punches back to back obviously we really
don't know but it's led to the series
feeling somewhat depressing
and that's kind of what you expect when
you release things on a wednesday
anyway that wraps up the video and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and your predictions for
the future we are running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of the zack snyder dc trilogy on the
30th of september and all you have to do
to begin with the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of what if episode 6 which
will be linked on screen right now we
went over the full thing and pointed out
all the easter eggs we could find so
definitely go check it out right after
this without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i mean paul
you take care of yourself and i'll see
you next week peace and have a good week
as well peace